hello and welcome to this video playing
inertia master branimir what is this
they all play this helped us in the last
game brownie Mia maximovich and the very
self okay I'll just I just play like
yeah like I'm YT in it she going and
isn't this like bad for white it feels
like a digital kind of thing like I had
this before really strange stuff him
Jack what did we had opening so um what
happens here maybe here just to keep
keep things closed this should have five
I have pretty good compensation for the
extra point something went really wrong
here for wide
three okay it's not strictly necessary i
guess just try to be very sound and
solid here I've got the phone and lots
of long-term advantages better porn
structure weird pieces on a one and so
find so forth threatening Bishop situ
now you can also go here on to g6 I
don't need to run into d4 here in one
move
yeah I still has a hard time to move his
pieces it's night before may be a good
option my queen looks a little bit a
little bit I would have squares but I
still can't do it I think yeah I don't
have a good score against and just like
plus 1 this is why I'm kind of very and
he is very bad rating with for some
reason I haven't scored so well against
him so I try to be observant okay Quincy
true now right
I can't even take their a couple of
times f6 takes takes rook h2 should be
winning a piece I think prevent that
okay so rookie age maybe of course I can
just take and go to the endgame yeah
maybe take this and then take it to look
each one should end the game actually
for Queenie to Queenie one light resides
I was a very strange opening yeah that's
the rest of where black has a couple of
moves but I think c5 is good it's the
most aggressive move black joe says okay
you play a chick around be happy with it
it's a it's it's a temple but often the
temper doesn't really help and here
already I feel like this is tricky for
white after Bishop after the bishop move
I'm definitely clearly better already I
mean how does he not loose material now
for nothing I think he cannot avoid it
this is down lie down right just just a
lost position here I mean you can always
blunder of course but it's more or less
winning for blood
now if you cannot prevent further losses
either scituate you one yeah here if it
takes their I've got rook h2 and then
I'm taking next and we need to yeah
there were many ways to win this opening
is really not good the way it was played
probably yeah maybe this is already good
for black I don't know what I do know is
that this is a good recipe against the
rest of if you look for line against
this 93 Bishop g5 I think c5 is pretty
good very often I bd7 is recommended and
I have played this as well but I think
c5 is just far more aggressive there is
some with C 596 you get the far more
interesting game in comparison so to go
for a c5 it's a good move okay well
thanks for watching